我是浙江大学的张秉盛
今天给大家讲
隐私计算线上目科的基础理论支
零支证明
首先简单自我介绍一下
我在2019年9月加入浙江大学
现任浙江大学百人计划研究员
在回国之前
是英国兰卡斯特大学的终身助理教授
在离职的时候身为终身副教授
也就是Reader
英国兰卡斯特大学
在英国三大大学排名体系中军在前十
是英国GCHQ认证的
第一批巴索
academic center of excellence in cybersecurity research
GCHQ就是英国国防部
我在兰卡斯特大学任head of security group
也就是网络空间安全中心的负责人
同时我也是program director of MSc in cybersecurity
就是网络空间安全硕士的系组人
主要的研究领域包括密码学
安全多方计算
领知证明
区块链安全
数据安全等等
学术成果在回国的时候
拿了7年前人
去年拿了科技部重检研发项目的项目负责人
也就是首席科学家
是网络空间安全治理专项
是世界上首个商用安全多方计算平台
Sherman的核心研发人员
今年来发表了若干偏高水平的学术论文
包括CCS、NDSS、euroCrypt、AsiaCrypt等等
在这当主要做隐私计算相关的国际标准
比如说ISO的27565就是我主导推进的
是一个基于领知证明的隐私保护指南标准
IQPE的P2842是一个安全多方计算的标准
在去年11月已经发布了
我在工作组认秘书
IQPE的2859是一个多摩泰安全的标准
现在还在推进
我在工作组认副主席
可能有些人知道我
我兴趣爱好比较广泛
曾经是浙江省二级设外武术教练
也在伦敦交过武术
有Paddy Advanced Open Water的潜水阵
以前在希腊的时候每周末会去潜水
也系统的学习过射击 射箭 赛车等等
像这个月我会去海南学习一下高空跳伞
去考USPA的高空跳伞证
为什么是紫色呢
因为还没有发生
但是如果当你们看见这个视频的时候
我还活着呢
我应该就有证明
下面是课程的主要的大纲
分为三部分
第一部分是零字证明的简介
第二是Sigma协议的介绍
第三是Fat Samuel Heuristic
也叫Fat Samuel变幻
首先是零字证明的简介
什么是零字证明呢
这个词你直接用英文翻译叫Zero Knowledge Prove
在密码学领域我们一般称为ZK
它是没有Ped 一般简称ZK
在隐私计算工业界
或者在ISO这种标准的领域
我们一般会称为ZKP
也就是它的英文手字母的缩写
Zero Knowledge Prove的三个字母的缩写ZKP
零字证明是一种新兴的密码学工具
它可以使得证明者通过一些协议
向验证者证明某一个声明是正确的
然后不泄露任何额外的信息
什么是声明呢
声明的英文叫Statement
任何一个层数都可以是声明
比如说我年薪超过10万
比如说我超过18岁
比如说我是男的
比如说今天杭州在下雨
比如说我五道口三套房
比如说我家里有矿
比如说我家里资产超过一个亿
这种都是一个Statement
然后如何去证明呢
就需要通过一些协议
比如说你去夜店
夜店的门位要确认你超过18岁
他问你看身份证
那么在这个过程中
其实你有没有考虑过
你泄露了很多额外不必要的信息
比如说这个门位看了你的生日
他知道你超过18岁
但他其实只需要知道
你超过18岁
他是没有必要知道你的生日
生日就是你额外泄露的信息
当然除此之外
你还泄露了很多其他的信息
比如说你在身份证上面的名字
也泄露给他
你的身份证号码门位也知道
你在身份证上面写的你的住址
门位也知道
这一些隐私信息是额外的信息
是没有必要让这个门位知道的
因为如果这个门位
仅仅想知道你超过18岁
那么如何去证明
你超过18岁
而不泄露这些额外的信息呢
那么今天讲的零字证明
可能会起到一些保护作用
零字证明分两
主要分两个类型
一个是交互式
一个是非交互式
交互式零字证明
我们把它叫做
interactive zero knowledge proof
其实你直接叫ZK
也是可以的
一般默认是交互式的
它是由高德瓦萨
Migali Rokov在1985年提出的
那么非交互式零字证明
是non-interactive zero knowledge proof
它是由Bloom Feldman-Migali
在1988年提出的
那么什么叫交互式
什么叫非交互式呢
交互式就是prover和verifier
它之前有弱干个message的交互
而非交互式指的是prover
直接把一个proof发给这个verifier
就直接把一个证明
发给一个verifier
只有一条message
所以没有交互
只有我发你东西
你不需要再还给我东西
那么这个就叫做非交互式
那么现在比较火的简洁
非交互式零字证明
或者简洁非交互式零字的argument
那么这个就在非交互式的领域
当然具体这一节课
是不会提到
简洁非交互式零字证明的
它是我硕士导师
Yans Grote创的一个notion
那么之前人们还不接受
因为他用了knowledge assumption
但是后来现在广泛使用
那么现在我们简单举例
来讲一下
为什么我们需要零字证明
比如说我们最常见的身份认证系统
你们登录身份认证系统的时候
最常见的应该是基于口令的
身份认证系统
也就是password
因为密码学的密码
和password的密码
我为了做区分
所以我们把password叫做口令
基于口令的身份认证系统
一般是你会填一个你的username
然后再填一个你的password
对吧
比如说我叫Alice
然后服务器会问你
你的password是什么
然后你把password发给它
那么这个过程是你password
会明文发给这个服务器
注意
虽然服务器存在你的password的
可能是加言的哈希
对吧
可能是经过一些处理的
但是你发给这个服务器的
是明文的你的password
那么你有没有想过这个过程
如果这个服务器是坏的的话
其实你有口令泄漏的风险
把这个password给你
那么你是一个坏人
你现在可以得到了我的password以后
就可以impersonate我
也就是说可以假装我
到真实的网站去登录
或者更有胜者
有一些人他在不同的网站
用同样的password
比如说有些人他
他为了方便记忆
他在银行的网页的密码
和他一些垃圾网站的密码
用的是同一个
那就会有更严重的问题
也就是说你在一个比较弱的
不可信的服务器上面泄漏了你的密码
那么他们可能会利用你的密码
去登录你的其他的账号
然后我们现在的一些密码泄漏
主要是通过这个途径
就是一些钓鱼网站什么
就是引用你把你的密码输给他
对吧
但你有没有想过在这个过程中
我们为什么要把密码告诉服务器呢
服务器想要知道什么
服务器想要知道你是你
对吧 认证嘛
你是你
服务器为什么要知道你的密码呢
服务器其实只需要知道
你知道你的密码
服务器是不需要知道你的密码的
只是因为我们现在的实现形式
比较low
我们现在的实现形式是服务器
这边存一份你的密码
你自己这边存一份你的密码
然后我们比对一下
这两个密码是一样的
所以我认为你知道你的密码
只是因为我们用了这种实现方式
而使得你需要把密码名门输给服务器
但是如果有了零知识证明
你就不需要这么做
比如说我们下面有一个例子
就是基于零知识证明的身份认证
同样你说你叫Alice
服务器现在问你
你知不知道你的密码
然后你说是我知道好
这是证明
然后你的证明又不泄露任何额外的信息
只证明了你知道你的密码
没有任何额外的信息
那么这个证明就是零知证明
那么在这个认证过程中
你的隐私就极大程度的得到了保护
那么什么是零知证明呢
我们简单通过一些现实当中的
这个实际的例子来渐渐的学习
那么下面我给你们一个
非色盲证明的一个协议
假设你是一个证明者
我是一个验证者
你想向我证明你不是色盲
但为了严谨期间
在这门课里面
我们假设色盲指的是红蓝色盲
如果你不是色盲
指的是你可以区分红色和蓝色
精彩而已
好他的做法是这样的
我有两个桶
一个桶里面都是篮球
一个桶里面都是红球
我在讲台后面
我随机从一个桶里面拿出一个小球
问你这个小球是什么颜色
然后你回答我
要不回答我蓝色
要不回答我红色
如果你回答错误
那你肯定是色吗
对吧好
那么如果你回答对了
也会有二分之一的概率
你是猜对的
因为要么红色要不蓝色
你随便猜一个
对吧
那么我怎么做呢
我把这个球放回去
然后再重新拿一个球出来
哎这是什么颜色
你说红色
我问你这是什么颜色
你说蓝色
那我重复10到20次
当然这只是一个虚拟的次数
你可以重复更多次
重复的越多
这个过伙我们会讲到
桑德尼斯会以指数的形式增加
也就是说我坏人作弊的概率
会以指数的形式减少
好这个假设10到20次
你都答对了
好我认为我相信你
你不是色盲
只要答错一次
你就是色盲
对吧
好
那么这个协议呢
有什么性质呢
我们先来分析一下
它有完备性或者叫完整性
英文叫completeness
也就是说如果这个声明是真的
如果你不是色盲
那么我一定会接受这个证明
也就是说你一定会通过这个协议
刚才我们设计的这个非色盲证明协议
如果你不是色盲
你一定会通过这个协议
这个叫completeness
第二个property
第二个性质叫soneness
我们或者翻译成可靠性
或者翻译成合理性
这个也就是说
如果我作为验证者接受了你的证明
也就是说这个协议结束以后
我说我相信你不是色盲
那么大概率你不是色盲
也就是这个声明大概率是真的
这就是soneness 可靠性
那么这两点很重要
第一点也就是说
如果你说的这个声明是真的
你一定能通过协议
第二点如果我接受了这个协议
那么大概率你说的这个声明是真的
对吧
好
那么零字证明确实需要这两个property
一个叫completeness
一个叫soneness
但零字证明还需要第三个property
也就是刚才我们定义中讲到的
不泄漏额外的信息
那么这个叫zero knowledge的property
那么我们现在来看一下
在刚才这个交互式的过程中
验证者有没有得到额外的信息
对吧
仔细想一下
当然这你也可以暂停一下想一下
我知道了你可以区分蓝色和红色
对吧
那么这句话其实就是你的声明
你的声明说你不是色吗
在我们这里就等价于你声明
你可以区分蓝色和红色
对吧
好
我确实知道
可以
好
但是我还知道了什么呢
我还知道了每个球
每个桶里面球的颜色
因为我从左边这个桶里面拿出这个球
我问你这是什么颜色
你告诉我这是蓝色
我从右边这个桶里面拿出这个球
是什么颜色
你告诉我这是红色
那么这两个桶里面球的颜色
是你告诉我的额外信息
假设我是色芒
那么我之前是不知道
这两个桶里面球是什么颜色的
现在我知道了
那么这个有什么坏处呢
这个很重要
有人觉得零知识证明
他所谓的额外的信息
指的是额外有关你声明的信息
或者有关你个人的信息
其实不是这么狭隘的
零知识证明是指
你除了这个statement之外
你不能有任何额外的信息
过伙会具体的更形象的
或者更严格的去定义这个额外的信息
但就这里你就假设
比如说我是个色芒
在考试前或者在测试前
等我们大家都在教室外面等
然后我跑进来先假装考官
把第一个人叫进来说
来你过来
然后我们拿A
这是什么颜色
他说蓝色
他说红色
我说好 你走吧
我相信你不是色芒
等到我自己进来的时候
考官把这个球拿出来的时候
我说这是红色
我是怎么知道这个红色的
不是第一个人告诉我们
这就是额外的信息
那么如何去改变这个协议
使得他具有零知识呢
那么过伙我们还是会定义
什么是零知识
暂且用你们的理解
去设想什么是零知识
那么还是两个桶
桶里面还是有蓝球和红球
这次我怎么做呢
我每次拿两个球
我要不两个球
用从同一个桶里面拿出来
我问你这两个球的颜色是一样的吗
要不这两个球
我从不同的桶里面拿出来
我问你这两个球的颜色是一样的吗
那你的回答要不是相同
要不是不同
对吧
要不是一样
要不是不一样
好
那么同样
你有二分之一概率
也就是即使你是色芒
你也能猜吗
要不一样
要不不一样
一共两种结果
那么我们重复很多次
比如说重复十到二十次
对吧
你只要答错一次
你就是色芒
如果你十次或者二十次都答对了
我相信你不是色芒
在这里仍然是红绿
红蓝色芒
然后我说好
我相信你可以走
那么在这个过程中
为什么我们说
它没有泄露任何额外的信息
或者证明者没有泄露任何额外的信息呢
那是因为这么回事
因为我从同一个桶里面拿出两个球
我问你他们颜色是一样的吗
你回答一样之前
我就知道他们的颜色是一样的
我可以预判你的答案
你在告诉我
你的答案其实是
你告诉我一个我已经知道的答案
或者我已经知道的事实
你告诉我一件我已经知道的事情
并没有增加我的知识
这个好理解吧
对吧
我如果两个小球是从两个不同的桶里面拿出来的
那么我自己知道你会说它是不一样的
但当你告诉我它是不一样的时候
我并没有增加任何额外的信息
也就是说如果你不是色芒
我早就可以预判
你想说什么
对吧
那么在这里有个先决条件
也就是说我们假设
即使我是色芒
我也知道
测试的时候是用的是一个是蓝的桶的球
一个是红的桶的球
也就是说我有两个桶的球
这个是大家都知道的鲜艳姿势
也就是这是一个安全假设
那么今天我们不会cover到安全假设
孤没的先这样听着
那么我们具体来formalize一下
什么是零知识性
也就是什么是zero knowledge
zero knowledge它指的是在整个协议过程中
验证者verify the view的试图
我看见了什么是view
view是我看见我收到的所有的信息
和我自己compute的所有的信息
这就是我的view
包括input
包括任何东西
你发给我的信息都是我的view
我作为验证者
我在整个协议中
我的试图是可以通过一个
不合验证者交互的一个模拟器
模拟出来的
被高效的模拟出来
也就是说在PBT
在多项式时间里就可以模拟出来的
然后这个模拟器
左边这个模拟器
你看见它并没有和prover交互
那么如果模拟器
它输出的transcript
也就是说它输出的交互的信息
和右边真实的交互的信息
是不可区分的
那么我们就认为
这个协议是具有零知识性的
主要零知识性
它其实指的是
这样一个思想实验
你需要存在一个simulator
一个模拟器
这个模拟器不合prover交互
它就能产生transcript
就是产生证明的整个过程
证明的记录
协议的记录
右边是交互的过程
真实的协议记录
我们希望虚拟的协议记录
和真实的协议记录
是不可区分的
那么为什么这样呢
它就是零知识性
因为这个模拟器
这个simulator
它不知道任何额外的信息
它只看见了你的statement
只看见了你的声明
它不知道任何额外的信息
它都可以产生transcript的记录
那就说明这个记录本身
它不含额外的信息
为什么
我用一个PPT的时间的一个machine
它可以通过声明就产生记录
那就说明你这个记录
哪怕人家不知道额外的信息
也能够产生
那就是simulator
是可以产生的
对吧
这里强调一点
很多人他会有误解
他觉得零知识证明
就是我们的隐私
被无条件的保护
你得到的是零知识
zero
真的是零知识
其实这是一个误解
零知识证明
尤其是零知识性
只是这张图里面的思想实验
你要存在一个模拟器
存在一个simulator
去simulator出transcript
那么至于这个不可区分性
是不是用到了computational assumption
这是另外一回事
好
具体来说
零知识性可以有很多种
比如说可以有perfect zero knowledge
也就是完美的零知识性
他讲的就是在整个协议过程中
证明者泄露给验证者的额外信息是零
这就是一个perfect zero knowledge
就真的是零
他主要讲的就是
我simulator出来的transcript
和真的transcript
是identical的分布
就是一模一样的分布
好
那么还有一种叫statistical zero knowledge
统计学意义上的零知识
就是在整个协议过程中
证明者泄露给验证者的额外信息
是可以被忽略的
而且这个可以被忽略的信息
是statistical distance
也就是和你的computational
是没有任何关系的
你有unbounded computational power
你有无限的计算力
也是这么一点信息
这就是statistical zero knowledge
那么有一些是基于算力假设的领知识
比如说computational zero knowledge
举个例子
我们假设你不可以break某一个加密算法
这个加密算法里面是什么
你不知道
比如说我们有一些假设叫
比如说DTH假设
比如说我们有一些各种各样的算力的假设
比如说factoring假设等等
D-Log的假设
那么基于这些假设
其实我们讲的是
在任何一个随机做相式的图灵机视角中
也就是在任何一个PBT他们的图灵机的视角中
simulate出来的transquered和真实的transquered
是不可区分的
其实是他们其实是不一样的
但是因为你的算力有限
你不可以区分他们
那么他这个就叫computational zero knowledge
证明者泄露给验证者的额外信息
是可以忽略的
但是只是针对PBT时间的那些机器是可以忽略的
好我们做个练习
我们刚才讲的领知证明的简单概念
那么我们做一个pook的练习
我手上现在没有pook牌
假设你有一副pook牌
好我让你抽一张
那么你随便抽一张
然后去掉大小王
然后我问你这张pook牌是什么颜色的
那么pook牌一共两种颜色
要不红色要不黑色对吧
我把整副牌洗一下给你
然后让你去抽一张
抽一张以后我问你这些什么颜色的
比如说你说这个红色的
好我说我不相信你是红
这一副这张牌是红色的
你可以证明给我这张牌是红色的吗
领知证明什么叫领知证明
不泄露给我任何额外的信息
什么是额外的信息
你只证明给我这张牌是红色的
不要告诉我这张牌是几点
不要告诉我这张牌是3是10是Queen是J是King
不要告诉我这些
红色的你也不要告诉我
这张牌是方块还是红桃
这两个也是额外的信息
你只要证明给我这张牌是红色的
就可以了
领知证明
好
那么如果你是看目科的
希望你手动点一下暂停
自己思考一下
有没有方法你可以证明给我
你手上这张牌是红色的
有些人会讲这个
我找一个探针
给你看一个像素点
如果你看见这个像素点是红色的
那么我就证明了
这个牌是红色的
如果这个点是黑色的
我就证明这个牌是黑色的
姑且我不知道有没有这样的点
可能会有
也就是这个牌的花色部分的点
当然这个操作太复杂了
那么一个比较好的做法是这个样子
因为你有一副牌
我洗了一下给你
你手上拿了抽了一张
这张在你手上你说这是红色的
对吧
怎么证明呢
你把剩下来那副牌里面
所有黑色的牌找出来
找出来以后全部给我
摊给我看
说所有的黑色牌都在这里
你这里查一张不少
好
那么我手上这张是不自然是红色的
那么这就证完了
这就是一个证明
而且这个证明是非交互是零知识证明
我有问题吗
我没有
对吧
你直接把黑色的牌全递给我
就证完了
这就是一个零知识证明协议
那么同理
如果我让你证手上的牌大于10
也很好证
你把小于10的牌全给我
就证完了
好
那我们继续
第二部分是Sigma协议的介绍
好
那么零知识证明
我们再回过头来讲一个更严谨一点的定义
在这个课程的刚一开始
我们讲了一个非常通俗的定义
说的是一个证明者
如何证明一个声明
给验证者不泄露任何额外的信息
那么更严谨的定义
我们需要假设一个NP的language
一个NP的语言
这个语言是L
那么这个语言
我们定义它是用一个二元关系去定义
叫RL
那么如果你不知道什么是NP language
在离散数学里面
一般语言的定义是一个集合
这个集合里面都是word
也就是这个语言的成员
都是合法的成员X
那么这个集合是怎么定义呢
只要存在一个witness
存在一个witnessW
然后你的这个statementX和W
它是属于这个二人关系R的
那么这些X都是这个语言的合法的成员
我们把这些X叫做statement
如果给一个statementX
你要证明这个X是属于这个languageL的
那么怎么做呢
通常的讲有个prover有个verify
对吧
这个prover会发消息给verify
verify会回消息给prover
prover会再发消息给verify
verify会再回消息给prover
对吧
那么双方各自都有各自的随机数的sauce
也就是说
其实你是允许使用随机数的
包括verify包括prover
那么在图里面的rp和rv
是它各自的随机的sauce
随机数的sauce
那么每一条消息
你可以基于前面通信的所有的消息
也就是说你要produce
第二个message
你可以看e-i-e的message
然后再通过计算
然后再发给别人
好
那么最后等你所有通信都完了
从me-mp都完了
然后这一些东西
我们把它叫做transcript
可以统一拿去做decision
要不prove
要不reject
要不accept
也就是说它要不接受你的证明
要不拒绝你的证明
好
那么核心的性质
就是之前讲的三点
completeness, soundness, zero knowledge
这是不变的
好
那么什么是Sigma写印呢
Sigma是一种特殊的三轮领知证明
非常非常特殊
如果有人跟你讲Sigma协议是领知证明
你其实是可以抬杠和他说不是的
过后我会解释为什么它不是的
首先它的三轮
三轮我们英文叫three move
但是我这里的轮
很可能有人会翻译成wrong的
也有人翻译成wrong的
根据不同的paper
对wrong的的定义是不一样的
有的wrong的的定义是认为是我发给你
你发给我算一轮
对吧
一个wrong的
有的paper觉得我发给你算一轮
你发给我算第二轮
这是不同的网络模型造成的
那么为了消除misunderstanding
我们把这个叫做three move
我发给你
你发给我
我在发给你
这个就叫Sigma protocol
那么为什么叫Sigma protocol呢
因为你把这三个线连起来
它就像大写的希腊字母Sigma
那么在学术界一般把第一条消息叫做A
第二条消息叫做E
第三条消息叫做Z
第一条消息是prover发一个承诺
commitment A
get verified
这个不是你所理解的承诺协议的承诺
我们只是把第一条消息叫做承诺
第二条消息是由V发给prover的一个challenge
一个挑战
那么在Sigma协议里面
我们希望这个挑战是public coin
也就是是一个随机的一个随机数
和你的第一条消息没有关系
好
然后当V收到了
当V发出了这个E以后
P它会回一个response
回一个反馈
反馈我们叫做Z
然后根据AeZ和你要prove the statement
verify它会输出accept或者reject
也就是它会做出判断
那么具体这个Sigma协议需要满足什么性质呢
那么Sigma协议是0知识证明of knowledge
也就是说是zero knowledge prove of knowledge
也就是说它是知识证明
0知识证明分为两种
一种叫做prove of membership
一种叫做prove of knowledge
比如说证明我超过18岁
这个没有知识对吧
我们没有讲到知识
那么如果你要作为0知识证明of knowledge
比如说我证明我知道我的password
这个是知识对吧
所以0知识证明有两种
Sigma protocol它是知识证明
也就是说即使你在协议设计的时候
你明知道这个东西是对的
你还是想让证明者去证明一下这个东西
仍然是有意义的
因为它是知识证明
然后我们在过会会讲到
我们会有knowledge extractor
我们会有一些知识提取器
去提取一些知识
所以在设计协议的时候
有的时候你会觉得很奇怪
明明这个事情它一定是对的
我们还需要让证明者去证明一下
因为你要证明的东西可能是totology
比如说你要证明这是一个group element
这就必定是个group element对吧
类似这种证明
那么同样我们还是在NpLanguage里面工作
比如说Language是由relation R决定的
对吧
那么这个领知证明
也就是说你想要说x它是属于L的
那你的知识就是有一个witness
存在一个witness
你的知识就是witness
我们希望extract你的witness
好
那么我讲了很多extractor
对吧
好
现在正式的定义来了
那么它需要一种额外的sunderness的定义
这个叫做知识合理性
knowledge soundness
注意我们之前传统的领知证明
它并没有knowledge soundness
刚刚传统的领知证明的sunderness
指的是如果我接受这个协议
你大概率说的是真的
没了
对吧
好
那么Sigma协议
它需要知识sunderness
也就是说如果你确实大概率
能够通过这个协议
那么必定存在一个extractor
就是一个知识提取器
这个知识提取器
它会和prover去进行互动
这个prover它脑子里有一个witness
这个w
它会和prover去互动
那么prover你可以想象成是一个
带软件带硬件的一个盒子
比如说别人说这个手机
就这么一个东西
你可以设断点
可以控制它的电源
可以控制它的卖充
可以rewind它
可以反复折腾
可以给它不一样的
同样的randomness
可以fix它的randomness
当然如果它externally需要用到randomness
对吧
如果它整个都是封闭的
自带randomness generator
你也没办法
反正就是这么一个东西
你可以通过prover的接口
去和它交互
可以设断点和它交互
大概就这么一个东西
extract在和它反复交互
交互完了以后
它可以输出w
就是输出正确的witness
那么我们就认为这个协议
是具有knowledge soundness
注意构建extract
是设计协议者的工作
你需要构建一个extract
这个extract的具体怎么操作
这个人者见人
智者见智
根据你的协议不同
这个不一样
但是extract有一个任务
就是在和prover进行反复反复
反复通信之后
它必须要出一个witness
prover它只有一个接口
这个接口就是证明接口
也就是说你不能自己在打个洞
去问它你的witness是什么
它不理你的
你只能通过函数
就是你这个协议的接口
去和它进行通信
好
那么具体来说
sigma protocol
它需要的是two special sound
二特殊合理性
two special sound的指的是
如果我们有两个transcript
这两个transcript的第一个message
就是你的commitment message
a是一样的
它的第二个message
就是challenge message是不一样的
它的第三个message
这个response message也是不一样的
也就是说a
e开始不一样
z开始不一样
如果你有两个这样的transcript
a,e,z,e,r
你把这两个transcript给这个extractor
那么这个extractor
它就能够提取出witness w
如果你满足这个性子
那么这个就叫two special sound
你需要两个transcript
如果你需要k一个transcript
那么这个就是generalize
叫k special sound
我没有说k special sound
是sigma protocol
我只是说有一些zero knowledge protocol
它是k special sound
sigma protocol必须二special sound
好,sigma protocol还有一个特点
就是它的零知识性的
指的是special honest verify
这就是为什么我说
如果有人跟你说
sigma协议是零知识证明
你其实是可以抬杠说
不是的,为什么
因为它的零知识性
是honest verify
也就是说在它这里
这个验证者必须是honest
必须是诚实的
如果这个验证者是malicious
sigma协议
它就不是零知识性
它不满足零知识性
它只能满足special honest verify
zero knowledge
prove,zero knowledge的这个性质
那么什么是special呢
special指的是
对于任意给定的e
challenge e
这个simulator
之前我们前面讲到的那个simulator
是simulator不和别人通信
自己输出A,E,Z这个transcript
我们就说它是零知识
对吧
是这么解释的
那么现在special就在于
这个simulator
这个e不是由它说的算
e是由坏人说的算
比如说verify说的算
其实是对于任意的e
对于任意一个e
我给这个simulator
这个simulator都能输出这个A,E,Z
为了区分我把它打来撇
其实这个e就和任意的e是同一个e
这个e撇和任意的e是同一个e
为了区分我把它改成a撇
e撇z撇
这是一个transcript
下面那部分是真正协议的transcript
A,E,Z
这两个transcript的概率分布
probability distribution要identical
也就是perfect
就是perfect match
你哪怕有unbounded computational power
你都没有办法区分这两个
只有达到这个要求
它才是Sigma协议
如果你看见了一些协议
这些协议它的零知识
它并没有达到perfect的吻合
perfect的概率吻合
那它就不是Sigma协议
有很多零知识证明
它其实在这里是装了漏洞的
它说我们是computational zero knowledge
这个就不是Sigma协议
那么下面我们举一个Sigma协议的
最有名的例子
那就是Shennaud identification protocol
也就是Shennaud的身份认证协议
也就是我们常见的prove
discreet log
离散对数的协议
我们假设这个计
是一个接为数数p的一个群
这个cyclic group
它的生成员是小计
那么在这里
你这个prove想要证明的是什么
想要证明的是x
等于g power of w
w是你的witness
然后x是你的statement
那么identification这个证明是干嘛用的呢
就比如说你要证明
你知道你的password对吧
好
现在我们把这个x发送给v
那么这个呢
就是到时候用来证明
你知道你的password的他们的handle
他拿来证明了这么一个信息
也就是你的statement
然后你的password是什么呢
是w
你每次认证的时候
你用一个0字证明去证明
你知道w就就结束了
然后整个证明过程
又不会洩漏w
所以这就是一个认证协议
好
具体怎么做呢
具体prove会先选一个
随机选一个t
t是在zp里面认一选
uniform random的选
选完了以后
它compute a等于g power of t
当然这些都是会取谋的
我们指的是这个群里面的operation
对吧
我们这个群是以惩罚群为例
如果你是eliptic curve
如果你是橢圆曲线的话
有一些是以惩罚形式表示的话
你就把它理解成t乘以g
这是一样的
没关系
这个它是g power of t在这里
那发生给v
然后v呢
它就随机选一个e
假设Lambda比特
我们假设这个速速p
它至少有Lambda比特
也就是说你可以fit in this group
好
e发生给p
p计算z等于t加上e乘以w
然后它把z再发生给v
那么v最后会验证一下
g power of z
就是g的z次密
是不是等于a乘以x的e次密
然后你可以验算一下
g的z次密
如果你把z等于t
加上e乘以w带进去
然后你如果有高中的数学知识
你就可以知道a乘以x的e次密
它其实是等于g的z次密
也就是说我们completeness
叫可靠性或者叫完备性
或者叫完整性
已经正完了
因为如果prover真的知道w
它是可以完成这个协议的
好
那么下面我们证明2特殊合理性
也就是2 special sound
假设我们有两个transcript
一个transcript是a ee z
一个transcript是a e2 z
那么这两个transcript
我把它写出来了
对吧
给extractor
extractor它是可以直接算出w的
w就等于z e-z2
除以e-e2
所以e不等于e2
所以分母不为0
那么z e-z2
你看一下左边的这两个equation
t就cancel掉了
它就等于e-e2
cancel掉 w
对吧
然后你把它除了以后
w就得到了
所以extractor也非常好构造
然后我们要证明special honest verifier
zero knowledge
也就是说给定任意的e
我们假设e是随机给的
给simulator
这个simulator先选择z
z它是从zp里面任意选
选完以后它再返向compute a
a是等于g power of z乘以x的负易词
然后它输出a e-z作为transcript
那么a e-z和原始的真实的协议
的a e-z的distribution
为什么是identical呢
你就这么看
你看原始的时候
我们compute的是a等于g power of t
对吧
t是任意选
那么因为t任意选
g是生成员
所以a是一个uniform random的group element
对吧
好
那么在这里呢
你看我们a是怎么算出来的
首先z是任意选
所以g power of z是一个uniform random的group element
对吧
好理解啊
乘以x的负易词
x的负易词肯定是个group element
你就不管它是什么
但是因为这个group element
成了一个uniform random的group element
这又是惩罚
然后这又是cyclic group
所以a的distribution也是uniform random
所以在我simulate出来的a e-z的a
和真实的a都是uniform random
是identical distribution
然后因为这个e是别人给我的
和这个也可能是verify给我的
和真实的这个协议里面verify的e是identical
是同一个人给
然后z呢
是因为当a确定
当e确定
z已经确定了
所以z没有任何浮动的空间了
所以整个distribution是identical
这两个distribution是identical
那么有人就问了
如果simulator这么行
那么为什么prover不直接wrong simulator
那么为什么prover不可以用simulator来作弊呢
原因是在这里
你要知道interactive proof
和你直接simulate this transcript
它中间少了一点信息
什么信息呢
the order of event
也就是说事件发生的时间
和事件发生的顺序
它没有这个信息
transcript里面是没有这个信息
也就是说它并不能够证明
你是先计算了a再计算了z
而事实上这个simulator是先计算了z
再计算了a
对吧
所以在真实的世界里
当你需要先给a
别人给你e再出z的时候
这个simulator用不了
而当你只看zero knowledge proof的定义的时候
你只要看这个transcript的时候
它并没有这个order的信息
它并没有洩漏你是先compute的什么的
所以你的simulator是可以使用
所以在真实的环境中
你的simulator是用不了
当然也有一个
你们也有个take away
take away就是如果你在虚拟机环境中
如果你的虚拟机是可以被别人设断点
被别人做一个快照
反复的rewind的
那么这种零值证明是有风险的
为什么
因为它可以rewind你的事件
对吧
那么相当于是order of event
是不能够很严格的被follow的
而且它还可以fix你的randomness
因为你的虚拟机
一般自己是没有randomness source
对吧
你是基于host的randomness
那么host在运行你的时候
如果它是malicious
它可以给你固定的randomness
然后可以rewind你
反复做这个零值证明
那这个零值证明肯定报道
那你肯定知识就泄漏了
那么同理
因为signature scheme一般来说
也是一个零值证明转换过去的
那么signature scheme在这种虚拟机的环境里面
也很容易挂掉
所以注意在虚拟机的环境里面
如果你要去做零值证明的话
是有风险的
第三部分
fat shall not change
那什么是fat shall not change
我们讲了这个非交互是零值证明
对吧
我直接发一个证明给你
就结束了
不用交互
这个非常好
这好在哪里呢
第一
这个验证者他不用再献
第二呢
我可以同时证明给所有人
而之前交互是零值证明
我只能证明给一个验证者
对吧
好
那么fat shall not change
或者叫fat shall not change
是fat和shamil在1986年提出的
它是一个变换
它可以把交互式的零值证明
变换成非交互式的零值证明
但需要用到random oracle
需要用到中文可能叫随机运
那么随机运是一个理想的模型
它在现实中没有找到任何attack
但是在理论上
它是不成立的
理论上其实
其实任何一个实际的协议
如果你用任意一个hash
去代替random oracle
是不一定是安全的
但在现实中
我们找不到一个攻击
所以被广泛使用random oracle model
好
那么下图是我们重复了
刚才的Sigma协议
对吧
给大家看一下
那么它的fat shall not change
关键就是它看到的第二个move
verify的第二个move是e
e它并不是基于任何message
就计算出来的
e是随机选的
所以它把e用hashi扩号XA代替调
这里就要讲到有好几点
第一点
很多人会简单
包括我在网上也看见
很多人会简单的写
e是等于hashi
of第一个message
就是hashi扩号A
这个是不对的
这是专门有文章给做攻击的
这个叫weak fat shall not change
heuristic
你必须要用strong fat shall not change
也就是说你的hashi里面
要包括statement
要包括之前所有的信息
这才对的
也就是hashi你的statement
再加上a出这个e
好
那么然后你就不需要verify了
你直接自己在家里
你先computer出a
你在hashi XA出e
你就假装这个e是verify给你的
你在computer的z
等于t加上e乘以w
然后这样你就把整套协议做完了
对吧
好
具体大概等这个样子
我先选个t
我再选一个a
我再计算出a
我再算出e
然后我再算出z
然后我把a和z
一起作为一个pro
发给verify
verify这一边
它也可以computer这个e
因为它知道x
它也看见了你的第一个move a
所以它可以算出e
对吧
然后它可以验证
g的z
是个等于a乘以x的e
这个验证是一样的
对吧
好
那么这里
为什么这个是可行的呢
因为还记得我们刚才讲的
order of event
这个事件发生的顺序
因为有了hashi
使得我们确定
你必定要先有a
才能够看见e
然后才能够computerz
对吧
而simulate
它是需要先看见e
然后选z
然后反推出这个a
对吧
因为这个hashi有单向性
你看见了e
你是没有办法反推出这个a的
而且这个hashi
在randon oracle模型下面
还要求它有intro
这个呢
其实我和很多数学家
去沟通Fat-Share-Milkyuristic的时候
他们完全不相信
完全听不懂
我说prova
你把statement x和a
用hashi做一遍
你出来的e就unpredictable
然后他们shocking
他们下一跳
他说这为什么是unpredictable
x我也知道
a我也知道
hashi是个deterministic algorithm
做出来的e
居然是一个具有intro的随技术
完全听不懂
对吧
这就是我说Fat-Share-Milkyuristic
里面用到randon oracle model
是个理想模型
它在现实世界中
其实是有一些问题的
但是我们没有找到任何实际的attack
然后很多隐私计算的协议
都在用hashi做randon oracle
都在这么用
当然有一些领之证明
它是不用hashi的
它用cis common reference stream
trusted setup
那个有它自己的问题
比如说trusted setup
common reference stream
里面有trapped off
那么trapped off
这个trapped off的存在
也非常非常麻烦
所以每一种treatment
都是一个treat off
就是不一定一个necessary
比另一个更好
看你的实用场景
randon oracle model
这个实用场景也非常非常多
而且现在在区块链领域
越来越受到别人的追捧
会比cis更受到别人的追捧
那么最后讲一下
我们浙大在主导的领之证明
ISO 275 565
在2022年的4月
也就是今年的4月进入WD阶段
主要是做领之证明
在隐私保护场景价
如何去使用
它的接口是什么样的
它的大概的流程是什么样的
它有哪些模块
这些模块应该怎么去set up
等等deployment
等等这些细节
那么也是我国首次在
这个领之证明领域提出了
一个国际标准
是ISO最近
我们在ISO看见的
这个最近10年内的
唯一一个领之证明的
一个国际标准
好
那么今天这个穆克
就先讲到这里
谢谢大家
如果大家有什么问题
可以email我
好
拜拜